le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
les cartables sont rangés les vacances
sont arrivées pour les enfants c'est
l'heure des sorties des loisirs et
pourquoi pas une escale sur saint leu le
jardin botanique de mascarin propose
plusieurs ateliers pendant les vacances
des activités originales sur un site
emblématique et enrichissant pour allier
découverte et divertissement nous avons
participé à trois d'entre elles aux
côtés des jeunes réunionnais
[Musique]
c'est un jardin dans lequel on cultive
les rires l'adresse est l'imagination
à chaque vacances scolaires le jardin
botanique de mascarin se transforme en
terrain de jeu pour l'occasion l'une des
dépendances s'est transformé en
véritable cirque ici ont marché sur la
tête on défie la gravité et en invente
de nouveaux modes de déplacement
à saint leu le jardin botanique abrite
des espèces endémiques et indigènes de
l'île un lieu de conservation gérés par
le département chaque année pendant les
vacances
le jardin botanique ouvre ses portes aux
jeunes réunionnais au programme cette
saison
atelier cirque photo ou déco pour les
marmailles de 3 à 15 ans mieux marc
lecerf ça m'intéresse on fait les bâtons
du diable ce que j'ai là y'a les
diabolos vers la balle et les matrices
voilà j'aime bien et peut-être que j'en
ferais des vrais cours moi j'ai commencé
par les acrobaties on est sur des autres
et si et tenir un peu différentes
manières ça me plaît parce que on
apprend des nouvelles choses que l'on
pourra pas faire tout le temps donc
toujours j'ai envie de revenir et comme
à la fois enfin spectacle c'est super
dans un bâtiment voisin
l'ambiance est plus studieuse plantes et
senteurs reste à l'honneur dans cet
atelier olfactif emmanuel l'allemand ou
après objectif fabriquer un mobile
odorant et certains participants
maîtrise bien le sujet ça fait longtemps
encore que je suis dit nathalie d'humour
de trois ans je trouve ça toujours aussi
cool fait tout le tour
quand est arrivée là tu me dit
christelle il est super sympa et au
conservatoire il est super jolie elle a
le droit de se promener
si hyper cool je pense que les parents
sont contents parce que justement
l'enfant se serve de sa tête de cema et
au bout de quatre jours il repart avec
quelque chose d'esthétique
tu as procurer du plaisir à fabriquer
dans le jardin arbustes et fleurs
servent cette fois de décor aux
photographes en herbe aux côtés de
thomas une dizaine de jeunes s'initient
à l'art de l'image blanc ça nous apprend
des choses et on apprend
l'appareil est comment on fait des
photos ne pas trop les centres et c'est
m un peu sur les côtés je trouve très
intéressant
bien l'après midi on fait des activités
en groupe c'est bien concéder nouveaux
amis si jamais entretenu de 5,6 savard
il est automatiquement la vitesse de la
lumière
ouais
pour ces graines d'artistes le meilleur
moment c'est encore celui où l'on
découvre le résultat de ces expériences
on est là pour apprendre mais aussi tout
en s'amusant et donc pendant ces
vacances c'est le moment de de s'amuser
de entre camarades entre enfants du même
âge le but final c'est qu'ils repartent
avec leur regard leur sensibilité et
qu'ils ont peut-être envie de faire à la
fois les vacances continuent à faire des
photos photographe acrobates et
décorateurs ont élu domicile au jardin
botanique jusqu'au 17 août prochain
c'est vraiment un véritable domaine avec
un sanctuaire de plantes endémiques
on a près de cap une espèce cultivée sur
quatre hectares et là nous allons
proposer donc aux jeunes de 3 à 15 ans d
activité pour les sensibiliser mais
aussi les faire découvrir et faire
connaître l'environnement naturel et
culturel de belles vacances en
perspective et un développement de de
leurs connaissances culturelles au
niveau de notre île et une ouverture sur
la connaissance du monde
le jardin botanique de mascarin est un
site historique devenu aujourd'hui ou
six scientifiques pédagogiques et
touristiques
les ateliers enfants s'adresse aux
jeunes de 3 à 15 ans qu'ils peuvent
s'essayer à la photographie aux arts du
cirque ou à la fabrication de mobiles
ces ateliers se déroulent jusqu'au 17
août au jardin botanique à saint leu
pour plus d'informations ou pour des
réservations vous pouvez appeler au 02
62 24 92 27 ou consulter le site du
département au www.cegedim.fr
[Musique]